I'm Gia I'm Zack and we own beetle house
the restaurant bar and today today we
are adults
baking with an easy-bake oven it's gonna
be a real gourmet I never had one of
these as a kid maybe that's why I'm bad
at cooking yeah I want to see what the
[ __ ] is up with this thing the problem
is is that we could only make it this
big that's it you think you were getting
[ __ ] four-course meals out of this
[ __ ] it's supposed to be an appetite
for a child scramble an egg on this
plate here we have a mix of cheese in
with the egg crack that egg right there
throw it in you bring it over here
that's not a technique come on pop it
open go see use the spoon to tap it
literally says press spoon now we've
just basically got a little bit of a egg
definitely Illinois take this just put
it over and yeah we'll do it like this
okay say cheese okay this looks like a
butt cheek looks like my butt we're
gonna try to put a little bit of this
egg you know what we didn't do we didn't
spray the pan it's a rookie mistake
oh wait what's this oh [ __ ] okay wait
undo it nice great
Oh beautiful very gentle The Stray love
it put the butt back in great oh that's
right what they did pizza sauce I'm not
gonna eat this do we have one happen uh
a soft tater over here broke in the oven
we go so we're supposed to put it right
in there
my parents next I want to put one on
each side as like two nips thank you
perfect I guess that's it we're cooking
I think I heard some sizzling sounds
might do it why are you so dramatic so
what do we do while we wait I don't know
I wish there was a way to like see what
was happening cuz I'm not gonna know if
it's overcooked or it's not maybe we
just need one too
oh why here sizzling I smell it smell it
okay cuz we gotta make sure it cooks
because look we don't want to get your
boys I'm not eating this
where'd the other prep go we had two
pizzas this is NACA is not cooked we're
gonna reap it it in for a little longer
cuz right now it just looks like yeah no
wait wait no this is the point is that
it was not going it didn't because it's
too tall okay so we're over the 13
minute mark now so we need to push this
guy through and see what we're ready oh
not too bad huh cool pepperoni idea
[Music]
it's in sure uh put your thing up there
thank you okay this one's called
breakfast Pisidia
eat at your own risk oh here's sizzling
No
something is burning I can smell it oh
we're all the pets that you put on there
maybe cuz you keep like cloaking it and
pepperoni now let's let's eat it go
ahead does it feel crispy big feel cook
that's crispy I mean I feel like the egg
has to be cooked try it
no you're literally eating dope egg
quesadilla oh oh oh
[Music]
easy-bake is not easy also it's also not
easy literally cooking Easy Bake Oven
sauce yes but it can be done technically
and it didn't come out bad I mean it's
not ideal
basically we [ __ ] this up big time I
think that if you use a regular oven
fantastic all that work with this we
could each have a bite
Oh bye I just don't think for please for
me I don't think it is either but I love
these makeup and I'm glad I got to try
it